J'étais aveugle de naissance jusqu'à récemment
et je vais vous expliquer maintenant ce que c'était
d'aller dans un McDonald's à
37 ans pour la première fois
[Musique]
ça a complètement changé tout vraiment
je veux dire que j'étais capable de faire des choses sur mon  avouez
que je n'ai jamais été capable de faire et vous savez que
j'ai pu faire beaucoup mais toujours avec
les gens c'est comme avoir un
sentiment supplémentaire que vous ne saviez pas que vous étiez il vous
manquait et c'est beaucoup apparemment
beaucoup de gens qui sont  dans ma situation
finissent en thérapie ils finissent tu sais
devoir réapprendre leur vie pour moi
personnellement j'ai raté certaines des choses
que tu aurais rencontrées dans ces
années
Je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup de films que vous avez vus, donc
c'est et je rattrape mon retard, je suis comme si je
venais de voir le Karate Kid et Jaws pour la
première fois et apparemment tout le monde a
vu qui
n'a jamais voyagé auparavant à cause de maintenant pour
être clair  les aveugles peuvent voyager mais si
les gens autour de vous qui
vous aident ne veulent pas voyager vous pourriez
ne pas euh dans mon cas je ne l'ai pas fait euh et donc pour
moi j'ai été vraiment choqué quand j'ai vu le
désert en Californie cette liberté et
être capable d'explorer des choses que je
n'étais pas capable d'explorer auparavant, comme j'ai
commencé à étudier la danse
[Musique]
Je m'asseyais juste dans mon placard et
parce que je pouvais voir jusqu'au bout avant
le bout de mon nez, j'appuyais comme euh
un  livre jusqu'à mes yeux et je traînais mon
nez dessus et je
lisais juste comme ça
pour dire quand il y a une
faiblesse, j'étais obligé de
vivre avec des personnes voyantes,
ils étaient comme si elle n'était pas aveugle, elle était
juste stupide, ils pouvaient voir les
grandes lunettes que j'avais, mais pour autant
que je suppose, le traiter et avoir de
la compassion  pour cela, certaines personnes l'ont fait, mais
les intimidateurs ne l'ont pas fait au moment où j'ai
atteint le
lycée quand j'avais environ
15 ans.
attrapez-moi, je pourrais faire
quelque chose à ce sujet
[Musique]
étranger
J'aurais pu recouvrer la vue quand j'étais
enfant mais l'assurance ne couvre pas
cette opération sauf si vous avez des cataractes,
elle en a couvert une partie, puis
Internet a payé le reste je  Je
n'ai pas fait de GoFundMe, j'avais un blog et
j'avais une présence et les gens ont insisté pour
m'aider et m'en sortir, donc la
réponse est la pauvreté, c'est pourquoi je ne l'ai pas eu
[Musique]
alors
euh il y a eu une opération au laser où  Je
devrais regarder cette lumière vive
et il y a une photo sur mon Instagram
où vous verrez que la lentille de mon œil est
découpée en tranches comme une planche de tic-tac-toe
qui n'est pas Photoshop et ce n'est pas comme
ce moment où vous obtenez juste votre
vision correcte et c'est comme boum c'est
fait donc c'est vraiment désorientant je veux dire je
me souviens juste d'avoir été très confus et
soulagé que ce soit fini il m'a fallu la majeure partie de
l'année pour arriver au point où je
voyais clairement dans les deux yeux
[Musique] les
étrangers
pensez que si vous êtes aveugle, vous
voyez comme un cadre noir comme littéralement
rien quand vous savez que vous pouvez être
gravement myope, vous pourriez
avoir des clignotants flottants, vous
pourriez avoir obstrué la vision, donc chaque
expérience en tant que personne aveugle va
sois différent